2022 une année assez particulière pour
le zoo safari de thoiry les soigneurs
ont assisté cet hiver et au printemps à
la naissance de plusieurs espèces rares
en cette période de printemps on a eu
pas mal de naissance dernièrement sur le
parc on a lu particulièrement beaucoup
de canidés cet hiver déjà ça a commencé
avec les chiens des buissons et les
loups à crinière et ensuite au printemps
on a eu les coyotes les renards polaires
et les loups arctiques avec quatre
louveteaux sept bébés coyotes et 8
renardeau au niveau des canidés c'est
une année spéciale ces naissances se
font de manière totalement naturelle et
parfois même spontanée même si les
soigneurs détecte des signes avant
coureurs comme l'éloignement de la
femelle ou le fait qu'elles creusent un
terrier la femelle a creusé à lui même
son propre terrier à l'intérieur du parc
dans son enclos la femme elle est le
couple de loups arctiques qui sont en
liberté du coup vraiment on les laisse
faire au niveau de la reproduction de
leur comportement naturel donc la
femelle à creuser son propre père y est
elle est allée mettre bas courant mai et
puis quelques semaines plus tard les
psys ont commencé à sortir de là de la
tanière ces nouvelles venues au monde
permettent également de sauvegarder des
espèces qui sont menacées ou en voie de
disparition un début de départ que c'est
effectivement la conservation c'est le
principe d'abord en fait les populations
captives de secours au cas où
effectivement les populations sauvages
venait à trop décroître voire à
disparaître l'an particulier on est
devant les oryx d'aravis une ex ps qui
dans les années 70 avait complètement
disparu du milieu naturel ne restait
plus que dans les parcs zoologiques et
grâce aux efforts justement de
différents parcs qui ont pu faire de la
reproduction avisés de réintroduction
n'a plus réintroduire des individus dans
leur milieu naturel et aujourd'hui on a
plusieurs milliers d'individus de rex
club d'arabie seuls trois parcs
zoologiques en europe accueille des
coyotes c'est donc une véritable fierté
pour touahri d'avoir eu une portée de
sept bébés pareil pour les lois arctique
cela faisait deux ans que le mâle et la
femelle tourner autour la portée de
quatre motos représente un
accomplissement pour les soigneurs
[Musique]